good morning John in the last few months
I have learned a lot about cancer and
about
myself and about like what it means to
be a living mortal animal of the two of
us you are definitely the one who has
traditionally thought more about death I
think about death but like in fun little
Silly Ways I'm not like actually
wrestling with the implications but
untreated Hodgkin lymphoma has like a 90
chance of killing you within five years
and it has like a 10 chance of killing
you if you do treat it my doctor who all
day long sees people who have cancer
most of them worse than mine thinks
these numbers sound great but I go to
the grocery store and mostly see people
who don't have cancer and so the numbers
sound terrible like nobody does things
intentionally with a 10 chance of death
even if they're very fun now after I got
staged and we knew that it was only in
one part of my body it was more like a
five percent chance that I would be dead
in five years which is better I told
this to a friend of mine who plays a lot
of Dungeons and Dragons and he said Hank
that's like a dc2 saving and I was like
why would you say that to me you've seen
me roll so many ones but also in
Dungeons and Dragons you roll a
constitution-saving throw and to find
out whether you will be affected by like
a disease or a poison and then you are
either affected or you are not
that's not what life's like this week my
doctor told me that I am in complete
remission from my cancer which you might
be thinking gosh that happened fast
Hodgkin lymphoma when it responds to
treatment tends to respond very well it
worked really well in my case it uh
worked about as good as it does I'll
show you pictures here is my scan before
which I don't love looking at this is a
pet scan which shows glucose uptake so
you see like my brain is eating a lot of
glucose it's getting filtered out by my
kidney at the bottom and an armpit you
see this big black mass of cancer that's
just consuming a lot of glucose because
it's dividing really fast because it's
cancer and after chemo boom like mostly
gone now they call this a dovil 2
there's still a little bit of increased
activity in the lymph nodes but that
basically is clinically not cancer
anymore and then we hit that same area
with a bunch of radiation to get rid of
any individual tiny little cells that
are still hanging out in there now this
has gone pretty much as good as possible
for me I didn't experience any of the
most dangerous side effects from the
chemo I didn't have to do very much
chemo it was in a really good spot for
radiation which meant we could do the
radiation which meant we could do less
chemo and most importantly my cancer was
susceptible to the treatment sometimes
it just isn't and we're not even sure
why but also like cancer treatment's no
joke and I've got stuff that I'm going
to be like living with for a long time
maybe the rest of my life I've got pain
from the radiation and from the surgery
over here I can't really lay on my left
side maybe someday I will be able to
again because of the chemotherapy my
chances of heart and lung disease are
significantly elevated for the rest of
my life my chances of getting leukemia
are significantly elevated for the rest
of my life my chances of other kinds of
cancer which is just cancer in general
are all increased both because of like
all the treatments and the scans but
also because I got cancer once and you
just are more likely to get cancer again
once you've had cancer once and the most
importantly like the highest risk is
relapse so they say that where I'm at
right now is remission and when you're
in permission you can relapse for me
there's about a 10 chance of that
happening in the next five years and if
that happens that's something that we're
gonna have to take on and as you might
expect all that comes with another side
effect a permanent anxiety like I don't
maybe some people can avoid that but I
don't think it's gonna be me they say
what doesn't kill you makes you stronger
they're wrong so I had a dc2 saving
throw I rolled my dice looks like I
almost definitely did not roll with one
I couldn't see him for a long time which
was annoying probably I rolled like
above a 10. but this isn't like a binary
thing it's a process I get to like roll
the die again every day for the rest of
my life and I don't get to see what I
rolled fun and I posted that I was in a
mission a lot of people and this is very
kind said Hank Green beat cancer and
I've been like thinking about that and
feeling a lot of different ways about it
like one way that people helped me
understand was that like look
I did the things I was supposed to do
and it was hard and that should be
celebrated and I agree like in that way
I beat cancer like I did the stuff I
took care of myself I even at times was
able to you know get up and out of bed
and do things that I love all that was
very hard it was
the hardest thing I've ever done
um and it wasn't even compared to what a
lot of people go through that hard uh
but it sucks but the truth resist
Simplicity I had someone ask after I
posted about this they're like I'm
confused is there any cancer inside of
you now and I was like I'm also confused
like we don't know whether or not
there's still cancer inside of me we
don't know if there is whether my immune
system will take care of it on its own
or if I will relapse and we'll have to
do more treatment Hodgkin lymphoma is
one of the cancers where doctors will
say that you can move past remission
into cure though even after you are
cured your chances of recurrence remain
much higher than the regular population
like the difference between relapse when
you get cancer again while you're in
remission and recurrence where you get
cancer again after you've been cured
isn't like a functional difference in
what the cancer is doing it's like a
statistical thing that we decide based
on how unlikely it is for the cancer to
come back after certain periods of time
and I kind I wish I didn't know that I
kind of wish I just thought oh if you're
cured then it won't come back but it
might still come back after you're cured
you are you remain at a much higher
chance of getting that same cancer again
even if it's been 10 years or 20 years
it's just much much lower than it was in
the first two or five years it's messy
it's medicine it's bodies and look if it
comes back in 10 or 20 years for me that
would actually probably be great because
my guess is we'll have even better
treatment different cancers are very
different from each other and I feel
very grateful that probably I have had a
very short if unpleasant experience with
this cancer but also I'm still in the
process I'm still in the journey my
relationship with my body is changed
forever it's just it's never going to be
that I'm never gonna feel the same as I
did right now I guess I just want to be
happy I want to be happy that I'm
through treatment I want to be happy
that I did it I want to be happy that I
probably won't get lymphoma again it
feels amazing to be feeling better and
even on some days occasionally almost
normal whatever that is John I'll see
you on Tuesday